Everyone in the family agrees. Edie's the youngest, and so she gets more attention. She gets more stuff. Ayla, her 15-year-old sister, puts it this way.
家里每个人都同意。Edie 是家里最小的，所以她得到了更多的关注。她得到的东西也更多。她 15 岁的姐姐 Ayla 是这样说的。
She's spoiled. For her birthday last year, she got a scooter, you know, one of those high-tech things, and then I got a CD. And my parents were like, yeah, well, you know, you'll be getting a car soon. But she'll get a car sometime, too, and-- yeah.
她被宠坏了。去年她生日，她得了一个滑板车，你知道的，就是那种高科技玩意儿，然后我只得了一张光盘。我父母当时说，哎呀，没关系，你知道的，你很快就能有车了。但她迟早也会有车的，所以……嗯，就是这样。
Even Edie sees it this way. One of our producers, Jane Feltes, is their cousin, and Jane got this out of the 10-year-old under tough, tough questioning.
连 Edie 自己也这么看。我们的一位制片人 Jane Feltes 是她们的表姐，Jane 在严厉的盘问下从这个 10 岁孩子口中套出了实话。
You or your sister, who gets treated better?
你和你姐姐，谁得到的待遇更好？
Me.
我。
Who gets more stuff?
谁得到的东西更多？
Me.
我。
Who gets punished more?
谁受的惩罚更多？
Ayla.
Ayla。
But who gets a worse punishment?
但谁受的惩罚更重？
Ayla.
Ayla。
Edie gets more attention. Edie gets more stuff, but she gets smaller stuff.
Edie 得到的关注更多。Edie 得到的东西更多，但她得到的东西比较小件。
This is Kathy, their mom.
这是她们的妈妈 Kathy。
Well, you want to treat them exactly the same, but that's hard to do because they're so different. Every kid is different, and with my two kids, they are totally opposite of each other. I mean, you do try to be fair, but you do treat them different. And you know, that's just the way it is. I don't know how else to say it.
嗯，你想一视同仁地对待她们，但这很难做到，因为她们太不一样了。每个孩子都是不同的，就我的两个孩子来说，她们完全是截然相反的。我的意思是，你确实试着公平，但你确实给予了她们不同的待遇。你知道，事实就是这样。我不知道还能怎么说。
You know, you don't really hear a positive word about favoritism very often. Most of us think that parents are supposed to treat all their kids exactly the same. But the fact is, sometimes it just doesn't matter.
你知道，你很少听到关于偏心有什么正面评价。我们大多数人都认为父母应该一视同仁地对待所有孩子。但事实是，有时这根本不重要。
I think what we're finding is what's more important than equal treatment is kids' perceptions about what they're getting.
我想我们发现的是，比平等对待更重要的是孩子对他们所得到的感受。
That's Amanda Kowal. She co-authored a study of 300 kids in 135 families, where they asked everyone in the families questions like, is one child favored over the other? Who gets praised more? Who are the parents stricter with? And OK, let's just start with the big news first, America. We are not giving equal treatment to our kids.
那是 Amanda Kowal。她参与合著了一项针对 135 个家庭中 300 名孩子的研究，他们询问了这些家庭中的每个人，比如：一个孩子是否比另一个更受偏爱？谁得到的表扬更多？父母对谁更严格？好了，美国，让我们先从大新闻开始吧。我们并没有平等地对待我们的孩子。
Very few kids actually said their parents were exactly equal in every aspect.
很少有孩子说他们的父母在每个方面都完全平等。
Really? How rare is that ideal?
真的吗？那个理想有多罕见？
I think we had about five kids.
我想大约只有五个孩子吧。
Out of 300?
在 300 个孩子里？
Out of about 300 that said, in every instance it was exactly equal.
在大约 300 个孩子中，他们说在每一个案例里都完全平等。
And all the others said--
那其他的孩子都说——
Most kids were able to think of a way that their parents did treat them differently.
大多数孩子都能想出父母对待他们有差异的地方。
But here's the other news flash. Most kids didn't care. 70%-- 70, seven, zero, 70% of the time-- when a kid said they or their sibling got praised more or punished more or whatever, they said it pretty much made sense to them. It pretty much seemed fair.
但还有一个突发新闻。大多数孩子根本不在乎。70%——七、零，70% 的时候——当孩子说他们或他们的兄弟姐妹受到更多表扬或惩罚，或者其他什么时，他们说这在他们看来很有道理。这看起来相当公平。
Most kids think differential treatment is fair, whether or not they're benefiting or their siblings are benefiting.
大多数孩子认为差异化对待是公平的，无论他们自己是否受益，或者他们的兄弟姐妹是否受益。
And they felt that way because why?
他们之所以这么觉得是因为为什么？
I think one of the most compelling reasons was when they felt that their sibling needed differential treatment or that they did. For example, one child said that his sibling didn't have very many friends, and he felt very sorry for him. So it made a lot of sense to him that his parents would spend more time with this sibling. If one child is older than another, he may have more chores. He may have a later curfew. He may also be punished more, potentially, because he has the ability to maybe get into more dangerous situations. She's driving now, so mom may punish her more when she makes mistakes or gets in trouble because she's more worried about her.
我认为最令人信服的原因之一是，当他们觉得他们的兄弟姐妹需要差异化对待，或者他们自己需要时。例如，一个孩子说他的兄弟没有多少朋友，他为他感到很难过。所以他觉得父母花更多时间在这个兄弟身上是很有道理的。如果一个孩子比另一个大，他可能需要承担更多的家务。他的宵禁时间可能更晚。他可能受到的惩罚也更多，因为他有能力进入更多危险的情况。姐姐现在开车了，所以当她犯错或惹麻烦时，妈妈可能会惩罚得更重，因为妈妈更担心她。
So it's important that it's fair. It's not important that it's equal.
所以重要的是公平。并不一定要相等。
Exactly. And I guess the basis of it is that each child feels they're getting what they need and what they want.
正是如此。我想其基础在于每个孩子都觉得他们得到了他们所需要的和想要的。
Which brings us back to Edie and her big sister Ayla. Ayla says it doesn't matter to her that she gets in trouble more and that Edie gets more stuff. Ayla's got band and band camp and choir. She loves school. She loves reading. Edie needs more attention from their parents, Ayla says. So she can have it. Like most of the kids in that study, Ayla understands why the two of them are treated differently. And she is fine with it.
这又让我们回到了 Edie 和她姐姐 Ayla 身上。Ayla 说她并不介意自己挨骂更多，也不介意 Edie 得到的东西更多。Ayla 有乐队、乐队夏令营和合唱团。她热爱学校。她热爱阅读。Ayla 说，Edie 需要父母更多的关注。所以她可以拥有它。像研究中的大多数孩子一样，Ayla 理解为什么她们两个会被区别对待。而且她对此没意见。
Well, I don't want them to treat us exactly the same or anything because everybody's different. And I understand the whole age difference thing. I'm at that age where you gotta watch out, I guess. Just troublemaker teenagers.
嗯，我不想让他们一模一样地对待我们什么的，因为每个人都不一样。我理解年龄差异这件事。我想我正处于那种需要注意的年龄。只是调皮捣蛋的青少年而已。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. Today in our program, in defense of special treatment here in the land of the free, the place where all men are created equal, and all kids. We have stories of when some people should be treated more equally than others.
来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。今天我们的节目主题是：捍卫特殊待遇。在这个自由的土地上，在这个所有人天生平等的国家，在所有孩子都平等的国家。我们讲述的是有些人有时应该比其他人得到更平等对待的故事。
Our show in four acts today. Act One, Lunchtime with the King of Ketchup. In that act, Jonathan Goldstein stands up for one man's right to be treated differently than you have ever been treated by waiters, store owners, and takeout delivery guys of every race, creed, and religion. Act Two, Except for that One Problem, It's Perfect. In that act, we hear the story of a woman who is solving something that has plagued prisons for years. And the only thing wrong with her solution is prison guards hate it. Act Three, Mommy's Psychic Helper. One woman gives special treatment to her two kids based on a horoscope given to them at birth. Act Four, The Way to a Boy's Heart Is Through His Stomach. In that act, a nine-year-old who never eats, and what that does to everyone around him. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目分为四幕。第一幕，《与番茄酱之王的午餐时间》。在这一幕中，Jonathan Goldstein 捍卫了一个男人的权利，他有权得到与你平时从各种种族、信仰和宗教的侍者、店主和外卖配送员那里得到的完全不同的待遇。第二幕，《除了那个问题，一切完美》。在这一幕中，我们听一位女性讲述她如何解决多年来困扰监狱的问题。她方案中唯一的问题是狱警讨厌它。第三幕，《妈妈的通灵助手》。一位母亲根据出生时拿到的星座运势给予两个孩子特殊的待遇。第四幕，《男孩的心是通过胃抓住的》。在这一幕中，一个从不吃东西的九岁孩子，以及这对他周围的人造成的影响。请继续收听。
Act One, Lunchtime With The King Of Ketchup.
第一幕，《与番茄酱之王的午餐时间》。
And now the story of a man with a simple mission in life, to give a little special treatment to a group of people whose contribution to society is often overlooked, the men and women of the food service industry, who, when they meet this guy, tend to give him a little special treatment in return. Jonathan Goldstein tells the tale.
现在讲述一个有着简单生活使命的男人的故事：给一群对社会贡献常被忽视的人们——餐饮服务行业的人员——给予一点特殊待遇。而当他们见到这个家伙时，往往也会反过来给他一点特殊待遇。Jonathan Goldstein 讲述了这个故事。
Howard Chackowicz and I have been friends since we were kids, and so I can say with great authority that almost every day for the past 10 years, Howard Chackowicz has either dined out or ordered in at least one of his meals. Sometimes when Howard isn't sure what he's in the mood for, he'll lift an empty hand up to his mouth and pretend that he's eating. He stares straight ahead, trying to figure out if he likes the taste of the imaginary food he is shoving into his mouth. Sometimes his hand is holding a hamburger, sometimes a fork wrapped in spaghetti, and other times, he's double-fisting either end of an invisible pork rib.
我和 Howard Chackowicz 从小就是朋友，所以我可以非常有权威地说，在过去 10 年里，几乎每天 Howard Chackowicz 不是外出就餐就是叫外卖。有时，当 Howard 不确定自己想吃什么时，他会把空手举到嘴边，假装自己在进食。他直视前方，试图分辨自己是否喜欢那些塞进嘴里的虚构食物的味道。有时他的手拿着汉堡，有时是叉子卷着意大利面，有时他两手各抓着一根看不见的猪肋排。
Howard's always loved restaurants. He was raised in a Jewish Eastern European household, where the very idea of a restaurant was a ridiculous piece of decadence, something for Cossacks and cocaine addicts who enjoyed flushing their money down the toilet. Restaurants had a transgressive allure, and as soon as Howard was old enough, he started sneaking away to them after school or sometimes on weekends while the whole family was still asleep.
Howard 一直热爱餐馆。他在一个犹太东欧家庭长大，在那里，餐馆的概念简直是一种荒谬的颓废，是给哥萨克人和吸食可卡因的人准备的，他们喜欢把钱冲进马桶。餐馆有一种越界的诱惑力，Howard 一到年纪，就开始在放学后或有时全家人还在睡觉的周末偷偷溜去那里。
In fact, Howard was the very first person I've ever dined out with alone without any family. We were 12 years old, and we ate at Atomics Pizzeria, a place just down the street from us. It was owned by a crotchety, old Greek man named Costa, who served ridiculously large portions of food. We'd get a plate of fries the size of a dead Shetland pony, but right alongside of it, Costa would place one measly packet of ketchup. When we asked for more, he looked at us like we had just asked for more blood from his mother's still-beating heart. Whereas I learned to ration, eating 400 to 500 French fries with a bottle-cap-sized dollop, Howard learned how to talk to Costa, how to win him over, how to make him see that giving us more ketchup was just the right thing to do. Along the way, Howard learned how to say in Greek, "Thank you, kind sir. Bless you for the ketchup," as well as the excellent [SPEAKING GREEK], "Here's many years to your ketchup."
事实上，Howard 是我认识的第一个跟我一起单独出去吃饭而不带任何家人的人。我们那时 12 岁，在 Atomcs 比萨店吃，那是离我们家只有一条街的地方。店主是一个名叫 Costa 的古怪希腊老头，他供应的食物份量大得离谱。我们要了一盘像死掉的谢德兰矮种马那么大的薯条，但 Costa 就在旁边放了一小袋可怜巴巴的番茄酱。当我们要求再加一点时，他看着我们就好像我们要从他母亲那颗还在跳动的心脏里要更多的血一样。虽然我学会了克制，用瓶盖大小的量吃 400 到 500 根炸薯条，但 Howard 学会了如何与 Costa 交谈，如何赢得他的好感，如何让他明白给我们更多的番茄酱是理所应当的。在这一过程中，Howard 学会了用希腊语说：“谢谢你，善良的先生。保佑你的番茄酱，”以及那句绝佳的“[希腊语]”，意思是“愿你的番茄酱长长久久。”
Ever since way back then, Howard has had a very special rapport with the men and women of the food service industry, and he has worked very hard over the years to cultivate this relationship.
从那时起，Howard 就与餐饮服务业的人们建立了一种非常特殊的默契，多年来他一直非常努力地培养这种关系。
This is my neighborhood here. I've been to every single restaurant in this neighborhood several times, so I feel like I can comment on every restaurant.
这是我的社区。这个社区里的每一家餐馆我都去过好几次，所以我感觉我可以对每一家餐馆进行点评。
A couple of weeks ago, Howard took me on a walking tour of the best places to eat in his neighborhood. I've walked into bakeries with Howard where the young girls and old men alike who worked there have dropped their doughnut tongs to cry out with joy, Howard! I've watched him get moved to the front of the line outside restaurants in Chinatown. When he's relating to a waiter or a delivery man, all that Howard sees is one person giving another person food. He talks to them as though they're friends, brothers even. His servers are able to sense his purity of vision, and they bestow on him in every exchange some little bit of special treatment.
几周前，Howard 带我进行了一次徒步旅行，去吃他社区里最好的地方。我和 Howard 走进面包店时，无论是在那里工作的年轻女孩还是老人都放下了甜甜圈夹子，欢呼着喊道：“Howard！”我看着他在唐人街餐馆外的队伍中被请到了最前面。当他与侍者或送餐员打交道时，Howard 眼中看到的只是一个人给另一个人提供食物。他与他们交谈就像他们是朋友，甚至是兄弟。他的服务人员能够感受到他愿景的纯粹，并在每次交流中给予他一点点特殊待遇。
Let me show you a ghost here. On the corner, there was a place called-- I'm not sure what that was. That used to called Le Defi, which is "The Challenge," and that was a really great place. And then they closed, and they moved right across the street, and they had $1.99 spaghetti meal. I would go there every day, and I brought a lot of friends.
我给你看个幽灵吧。在拐角处，曾经有一家叫——我不确定叫什么了。那曾经叫 Le Defi，意思是“挑战”，那是个非常好的地方。后来他们倒闭了，搬到了街对面，他们有 1.99 美元的意面餐。我每天都去那里，还带了很多朋友。
But it got to the point where, when I came in, I was actually able to serve myself. That's how close we got. We'd go in. They'd greet me, and they wouldn't even get up. I would go, and I would pour myself coffee, and I would actually serve other people coffee. I'd say,"More coffee, sir?" At first, it was  a novelty. Then they got very used it. They actually liked it. The other funny thing is, too, one time they actually let me make toast and stuff there, so make some of my food. That's actually a true story.
但后来发展到，我一进去，竟然能自己服务自己。我们关系就是那么亲密。我们进去。他们会跟我打招呼，甚至都不会站起来。我会去给自己倒咖啡，实际上还会给别人倒咖啡。我会说：“还要咖啡吗，先生？”起初，这是一种新鲜事。后来他们习惯了。他们其实很喜欢。另一件有趣的事情是，有一次他们甚至让我自己在那里做吐司什么的，所以能做一些我自己的食物。这可是真实的故事。
We come to a little shop on the corner.
我们来到拐角处的一家小店。
Like, you wanna go in here? This is my friend. This is my friend Tino.
比如，你想进去吗？这是我的朋友。这是我的朋友 Tino。
Where are going into right now?
我们现在要去哪里？
This is Chez Vito. It's a great butcher shop, an Italian butcher shop.
这是 Chez Vito。这是一个很棒的肉店，一家意大利肉店。
Howard takes me inside and makes the rounds, saying hi to everyone, even craning his head into the kitchen in the back so as not to snub a soul.
Howard 带我进去转了一圈，跟每个人打招呼，甚至把头伸进后面的厨房，以免冷落任何一个人。
Hello.
你好。
When he's done, he stops at the cash to buy a few things, and the owner throws a small box of cookies into his bag. He says they're on the house.
打完招呼，他在收银台买了几样东西，店主往他的袋子里扔了一小盒饼干。他说那是送的。
All right, what just happened is that Tino's given me a free box of Lazzaroni Saronno, which I've never even had before. So Tino's saying that I'm nice, but he is the nicest. These guys are the nicest, and that's why I say Chez Vito's the best butcher shop.
好吧，刚才发生的事情是 Tino 给了我一盒免费的 Lazzaroni Saronno，我以前从来没吃过。所以 Tino 说我很友善，但他才是最友善的。这些家伙是最棒的，这就是为什么我说 Chez Vito 是最好的肉店。
I haven't gotten free cookies from a bakery since I was maybe eight years old, and that probably wasn't achieved without the use of fake tears. It pays to be Howard. He always gets a little something extra. In fact, Howard is such a beloved figure in the neighborhood that whenever our friend Tucker goes in to get takeout from Sarah's, a local Middle Eastern restaurant, he'll tell whoever is serving him that, in fact, the food was not for him, but that he was picking it up for Howard. This earned him portions that were almost twice as large as what he'd normally get. "Howard, he is the best man," his server would say, as he piled food onto his plate. "You are so lucky to have a friend like Howard." Indeed, he was.
我从八岁左右起就没在面包店拿到过免费饼干了，而且那可能还是靠假哭得来的。做 Howard 真划算。他总能得到一点额外的东西。事实上，Howard 是社区里如此受欢迎的人物，以至于每当我们的朋友 Tucker 去当地一家中东餐馆 Sarah’s 买外卖时，他都会告诉服务员，食物其实不是他吃的，而是替 Howard 买的。这让他得到的份量几乎比正常情况多出一倍。“Howard，他是最好的人，”服务员在往他的盘子里堆食物时会这样说，“你有 Howard 这样的朋友真是太幸运了。”确实，他很幸运。
But the funny thing is that Howard is so doted upon when he eats in restaurants that sometimes it makes it difficult for him to just sit back and enjoy his meal. He feels he has to balance things out, and so he dotes right back. Because of that, it can be hard to carry on a conversation with him. His eyes will nervously scan the restaurant for any way he can be of help to the waiting staff. Howard's ears can detect the muted clink of cutlery falling to the carpet from clear across the room. And when he does, he'll do a kind of concerned gym-coach trot over to the mishandled piece of silverware and pluck it up off the floor.
但有趣的是，Howard 在餐馆吃饭时总是受到如此多的呵护，以至于有时这让他很难安坐并享受他的餐点。他觉得他必须平衡一下，所以他也同样呵护对方。正因为如此，很难和他进行交谈。他的眼睛会紧张地扫描餐馆，寻找任何可以帮助服务人员的方法。Howard 的耳朵能从房间对面听到餐具掉在地毯上的沉闷响声。而当他听到时，他会以一种关切的姿势跑过去，把被弄掉的餐具从地上捡起来。
So as much as Howard loves restaurants, when he really wants to relax, he'll get home delivery. And since it was nearing lunch time, rather than step into one of the many restaurants we were passing, Howard ushered us back in the direction of his house to dial out for our grub. At his place, he pulled open his top kitchen drawer, and I saw the many choices that lay before us.
所以尽管 Howard 热爱餐馆，但当他真的想放松时，他会选择外卖送餐。因为快到午餐时间了，比起走进我们经过的众多餐馆，Howard 把我们带回他家方向，打电话叫外卖填肚子。在他家里，他拉开顶层的厨房抽屉，我看到了摆在我们面前的众多选择。
There's about 400 menus in that drawer.
那个抽屉里大约有 400 份菜单。
I wouldn't say that's 400. I'd love to count it. I'd say if this handful is about 10-- 10, 20, 30, 40, 50, 60, 70--
我不会说那是 400 份。我真想数一数。我会说如果这一把大约是 10 份——10，20，30，40，50，60，70……
As much as restaurant owners and waiters love Howard, it's delivery men who really, really love him. I mean, who among us even knows their delivery man's name? Howard knows their names and the names of their wives and children. When they come to his door, he invites them in and offers them water. And in return, they'll actually call Howard later on to see if his meal was to his liking, that it was warm enough, that there was enough ketchup.
尽管餐馆老板和侍者喜欢 Howard，但送餐员才真是非常、非常喜欢他。我的意思是，我们中间有谁知道送餐员的名字？Howard 知道他们的名字，还有他们妻子和孩子的名字。当他们来到他门口，他邀请他们进来并给他们水。作为回报，他们以后真的会打电话给 Howard，看看他的餐点是否合胃口，是否够热，番茄酱是否够用。
190, 200-- this is very embarrassing-- 210, 220, 230, about 250 menus in here. There are some doubles, for sure, or even multiple copies, but only of restaurants I order from all the time.
190，200——这太尴尬了——210，220，230，这里大约 250 份菜单。肯定有一些重复的，甚至有多份副本，但只针对我经常订餐的那些餐馆。
We decide to order from Howard's favorite restaurant, a souvlaki place called The Greek Village.
我们决定订 Howard 最喜欢的餐馆，一家叫“希腊村”的烤肉店。
I'm going to take a Number 10, the two-gyro pita. And I think that's it. Thanks, have a nice day.
我要一份 10 号餐，两份希腊旋饼烤肉。我想就这样。谢谢，祝你有愉快的一天。
While we wait for the food, Howard waves me over and opens his kitchen cupboard to reveal physical proof of his good standing with the service industry.
在等食物的时候，Howard 招手让我过去，打开他的厨房柜橱，展示他与服务业良好关系的物证。
Here we go. These are all bags of ketchup, salt, soy sauce.
看这里。这些全都是番茄酱、盐、酱油袋。
And this is all from takeout?
这些全都是外卖来的？
Yeah.
是啊。
And these are like big bags full of nothing but ketchup?
这些像大袋子一样装的除了番茄酱什么都没有吗？
Ah, there's some soy sauce.
啊，还有些酱油。
So gone are the days where you had to wheedle out a single packet out of Costa's hands for your French fries?
所以，那些不得不从 Costa 手里乞求一包番茄酱来配炸薯条的日子已经一去不复返了？
It's true that I have so much now, you know. I have so many packets here. But no matter how many packets I amass, it will never catch up to what I missed as a child: ketchup.
确实我现在有很多了，你知道。我这儿有这么多包。但无论我积累了多少包，永远也比不上我童年时错过的那些：番茄酱。
[KNOCK ON THE DOOR]
[敲门声]
Then, with vaudeville timing, our delivery arrives.
然后，伴随着杂耍般的时间掌握，我们的外卖到了。
Hey, Shamir!
嘿，Shamir！
Howard greets the delivery man like an old friend he hasn't seen in quite some time.
Howard 像迎接一位许久未见的老朋友一样迎接这位送餐员。
Thanks so much, man.
太谢谢你了，伙计。
Your friend, he's a beautiful man. He's such a nice man, I'm telling you.
你的朋友，他是个了不起的人。他真是个非常好的人，我跟你说。
I didn't get you in trouble, though, right?
我没让你惹上麻烦吧？
The best customer in Montreal I have. Each time I come, he give me apple. He give me a juice. He give me everything.
他在蒙特利尔是我最好的顾客。每次我来，他都会给我苹果。给我果汁。他什么都给。
When I order in, like most people, I figure these guys want out of my house as badly as a bird that's accidentally flown in down the chimney, and I assist in their passage, usually having the exact change with a tip all ready for them at the door. But at Howard's house, delivery men stay a long time. They seem to want to.
当我叫外卖时，像大多数人一样，我以为这些家伙想逃离我家，就像一只不小心从烟囱飞进来的鸟一样，我通常会准备好确切的零钱和小费在门口等着，帮助他们尽快离开。但在 Howard 家，送餐员会留很久。他们似乎愿意这样。
Shamir, can I offer you something?
Shamir，我可以给你点什么吗？
No, thank you, thank you. Thank you.
不，谢谢，谢谢。谢谢你。
Yeah, so Marvin's not working there any more?
是啊，那么 Marvin 不在那儿工作了吗？
No, because I think he  find some other job.
不，因为我想他找到了其他工作。
Oh, OK, OK. Actually, I  feel so bad. When I call, I want to ask for Shamir. I feel like, well, we don't know who you're going to get.
哦，好吧，好的。其实，我感觉挺糟的。我打电话时，我想找 Shamir。我感觉，好吧，我们不知道会是谁来送。
Well,  you don't have to feel bad.
好吧，你没必要感觉糟糕。
I know, but I don't want to get you in trouble.
我知道，但我不想让你惹上麻烦。
After about 10 minutes of this, I just want to eat. I find myself eyeing the bag of souvlaki lying on the floor like a campground bear. I realize then that I'm just not made of the same stuff as Howard. And I never will be.
大约 10 分钟后，我只想吃东西了。我发现自己像一头露营地的熊一样盯着地板上的烤肉袋。那一刻我意识到我并没有 Howard 那样的特质。而且我永远也不会有。
I can't offer you something?
我真的不能给你点什么吗？
No. Thank you very much. Thank you. So thank you--
不。非常感谢。谢谢你。所以谢谢——
Thank you so much, Shamir. I thank you, man.
太谢谢你了，Shamir。谢谢你，伙计。
I thank you, Howard.
我也谢谢你，Howard。
Thank you for your kindness.
谢谢你的善意。
Thank you.
谢谢。
You're the best. It's the best restaurant with the best guy.
你是最棒的。这是最好的餐馆，有最好的人。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Yeah, you're very kind. Thank you for your time today, Shamir. See you later, man. Thanks, Shamir. He's such a good guy.
是啊，你非常善良。谢谢你今天的时间，Shamir。回头见，伙计。谢谢，Shamir。他真是个好人。
When we finally sit down to eat, I can't even get Howard to admit that he's doing anything so special with guys like Shamir. We go back and forth on this.
当我们终于坐下来吃饭时，我甚至无法让 Howard 承认他在 Shamir 这些人身上做了什么特别的事。我们就此展开了争论。
Yeah, because, I mean, most people won't go to the extent that you do, which is why you have guys that work the telephone coming by your house to meet you. That probably doesn't happen that often.
是啊，因为，我是说，大多数人不会做到你那种程度，这就是为什么那些接电话的员工会亲自到你家来见你。那可能并不常发生。
Well, I really believe I don't really do anything. I'm nice to them.
嗯，我真的相信我没做什么。我只是对他们友好。
But, I mean, just empirically, you have to see at this point that you're getting responded to differently than most people, so there must be something different, no?
但是，我是说，从经验来看，在这个时候你必须看到你得到的反馈与大多数人不同，所以肯定有什么不同之处，对吧？
You know, if someone's going to come to my door more than a few times and they know my face and they're saying how are you, I'm going to start treating that person like a human being. And most people I think are probably rude to them. Like, most people that I know give delivery men a buck, and I think that they have a harder job than a waiter or a waitress, because here's a guy who takes your food, gets into a car, risks his life, goes into traffic--
你知道，如果有人来我家不止几次，而且他们认识我的脸，还会问候我，我就会开始把那个人当作人类来对待。而我觉得大多数人可能对他们很粗鲁。比如，我知道的大多数人给送餐员一块钱，而我觉得他们比侍者或女侍者工作更辛苦，因为这家伙拿着你的食物，钻进车里，冒着生命危险，冲进交通中——
Hang on a second. Risks his life?
等一下。冒着生命危险？
Oh, you know, he's driving a car, you know?
哦，你知道，他在开车，你知道吗？
Howard's worked all kinds of food service jobs himself, as a waiter, a bus boy, a short order cook. And he says that, as a result, he absolutely loathes the feeling of being served. There's something that just feels embarrassing and unnatural about it. But it even goes further than that.
Howard 自己也做过各种餐饮服务工作，做过侍者、餐桌清理工、快餐厨师。他说，结果就是他非常讨厌被服务的感觉。这总让人感到尴尬和不自然。但这甚至比那还要深远。
In his interactions with the service industry, he's looking for a particular feeling, a kind of cozy moment where he can palpably sense that the waiter has forgotten that he is a waiter and that they are both simply relating as human beings. And then, once he knows this, once he knows they're both getting along and everyone's happy, he can move on. He isn't looking for anything else from them. His motives are pure that way. But these kinds of special moments don't come without strings attached, and sometimes Howard gets into trouble.
在他与服务业的互动中，他寻找的是一种特殊的感觉，一种温馨的时刻，在那里他能明显感觉到侍者已经忘记了他是一名侍者，而他们两人只是作为人类在交往。然后，一旦他知道这一点，一旦他知道他们相处愉快，每个人都很开心，他就可以继续做别的事了。他没有从他们那里寻求任何其他东西。他的动机在这一点上是纯粹的。但这种特殊的时刻并非没有附加条件，有时 Howard 会因此惹上麻烦。
Earlier in the day, during our walking tour, there was one place we didn't stop into, a little convenience store around the corner. Howard became uncharacteristically somber and quiet as we walked by the storefront window. The owners, a Greek woman in her 60s named Vula, and her older sister, used to be pretty friendly with him. Sometimes Vula wouldn't charge him the tax on his chocolate bar, and on occasion, she'd have him sit behind the counter with her on a plastic milk crate. It wasn't much, but it was still more than what the other customers got, and it made Howard feel special. But then, at a certain point, things started to get more intense.
早些时候，在我们徒步旅行期间，有一个地方我们没进去，那是拐角处的一家小便利店。当我们走过店面橱窗时，Howard 变得异常沉重和安静。店主是一位 60 多岁的希腊女士 Vula 和她的姐姐，以前和他相当友好。有时 Vula 不会收他的巧克力棒税，有时她还会让他坐在收银台后面，和他坐在塑料奶箱上。这没什么大不了，但这仍然比其他顾客得到的要多，这让 Howard 感到很特别。但后来，在某个时刻，事情开始变得更加激烈。
There had been several holdups there by knife point, gunpoint, and I felt really bad for them. I'd see them really shook up. And they're kind of tough ladies, but they're alone. And I told them, I said, if you ever need anything, if there's any trouble or something, I'm just around the corner. You give me a call. And I really meant it like in case of emergency or, you know, just that there'd be someone they can call, like some kind of community-- some kind of effort at community. But she would call every day.
那里发生过几次持刀、持枪抢劫，我真的为她们感到难过。我会看到她们受到很大的惊吓。她们算是相当坚强的女性，但她们是孤身一人。我告诉她们，我说，如果你们需要什么，如果有麻烦或什么的，我就在拐角处。你们可以打电话给我。我是真心实意地指在紧急情况下，或者，你知道，只是为了让她们有人可以打电话，就像某种社区——某种社区努力。但她每天都会打。
She would call him for all kinds of reasons, to have him come by and fix things or to run errands for her, and he would try his best to be accommodating. She'd even call him just to chat. Even though all of this was more than Howard could shoulder, he was reluctant to put an end to it. It was only after the calls got later into the night at 1:00 and 2:00 in the morning that Howard's friends started insisting he tell her that enough was enough. And against his better judgment, he did so. Howard wonders if it was right to give her his number in the first place.
她会因为各种原因打电话给他，让他过去修理东西或者为她跑腿，他会尽力给予配合。她甚至会打电话给他仅仅是为了聊天。尽管这一切已经超出了 Howard 所能承担的范围，但他还是不忍心结束它。直到电话打到深夜 1 点和 2 点，Howard 的朋友们开始坚持让他告诉她到此为止。违背了自己的意愿，他还是照做了。Howard 不禁怀疑当初给她电话号码是不是正确的。
I made that offer, assuming that it would be understood that there's a cutoff point. But to another person, you know, that offer is a real genuine offer. If I need help, I'm going to call you. And she did. And maybe she's the one that's right. So it's ironic that just being nice to someone actually had the adverse effect, the opposite effect, and it ended up being like a disaster, and now two people are not even friendly with each other.
我提出那个提议时，以为对方会理解这里有一个截止点。但对另一个人来说，你知道，那个提议是一个非常真诚的提议。如果我需要帮助，我会打电话给你。她也确实打了。也许她才是对的。所以讽刺的是，仅仅对某人友善实际上产生了适得其反的效果，产生了相反的影响，结果变成了一场灾难，现在两个人甚至连朋友都不是了。
There have been other disasters for Howard, disasters where he was the one who went a little too far. Like, there's the time he became so consumed with helping this neighborhood Chinese restaurant that, without being asked, he took it upon himself to draw pamphlets for the place. The owner accepted Howard's flyers but never circulated them. Later, the owner picked a screaming fight with Howard over an order, and Howard never went back.
Howard 还经历过其他灾难，那些他有点走得太远的灾难。比如，有一次他变得如此沉迷于帮助这家社区中餐馆，以至于在没被要求的情况下，他自作主张为这家店印制了宣传单。店主接受了 Howard 的传单，但从未发放。后来，店主因为一份订单与 Howard 发生了激烈的争吵，Howard 再也没去过那里。
And then there was the time he brought in beautiful framed photos of Lebanon to his favorite Lebanese restaurant so they could be reminded of home, but the photos were never hung up nor were they ever referred to again.
还有一次，他把他最喜欢的黎巴嫩餐馆带去了漂亮的黎巴嫩装框照片，这样他们就能想起家乡，但照片从没被挂起来，也没被提起过。
But for Howard, those things don't matter, and I know that he'd probably even do them all again. There are so many other moments that make his good intentions feel repaid in full. Some of his favorites are when delivery men he knows pass him by in their cars as he's walking down the street. It shocks him out of his reverie when they honk their horns in a quick, affectionate burst. For a brief moment, it feels like a reassuring slap on the back. Howard thinks to himself that they're the best, and it fills him with so much gratitude that if he had a pear or a peach in his coat pocket, he would wave them over and give it to them.
但对 Howard 来说，这些都不重要，我知道他可能甚至会再做一次。还有太多其他的时刻让他觉得他的好意得到了充分的回报。他最喜欢的一些时刻是，他熟悉的送餐员在街上开车路过他身边时。当他们快速、亲切地按喇叭时，这让他从沉思中惊醒。那一瞬间，感觉就像是在背上轻轻拍了一下给予鼓励。Howard 心想他们是最棒的，这让他充满了感激，如果他外套口袋里有梨或桃子，他会挥手叫他们过来，把水果给他们。
Jonathan Goldstein is currently writing his own version of the Bible. He is the host of a new upcoming series on CBC Radio called Wiretap.
Jonathan Goldstein 目前正在撰写他自己版本的《圣经》。他是加拿大广播公司电台即将推出的新系列节目《Wiretap》的主持人。
[MUSIC - "MAKE ME SMILE (COME UP AND SEE ME)" BY STEVE HARLEY & COCKNEY REBEL]
[音乐 - Steve Harley & Cockney Rebel 的《Make Me Smile (Come Up And See Me)》]
Act Two, Except For That One Problem, It Is Perfect.
第二幕，《除了那个问题，一切完美》。
Prisons operate on the idea that if inmates don't control themselves they get consequences, punishments. So what do you do with inmates who don't understand consequences, whose emotions take over? Well, there's this thing called Borderline Personality Disorder.
监狱的运行理念是：如果囚犯不能控制自己，他们就会面临后果，遭受惩罚。那么，对于那些不理解后果、情绪失控的囚犯，你该怎么办？嗯，有一种东西叫边缘性人格障碍。
People with this disorder are ruled by their emotions. They are hypersensitive. They demand attention. They mutilate themselves. They attempt suicide. And in prison, they end up spending a lot of time in isolation cells. They require a lot of time from guards and medical personnel. They clog the system. They cost millions of dollars. They are a huge management problem. Medication doesn't work on this disorder, and psychoanalysis only makes them worse. They're too unstable.
患有这种障碍的人受情绪支配。他们过度敏感。他们寻求关注。他们自残。他们尝试自杀。在监狱里，他们最终在隔离室里度过了大量时间。他们需要狱警和医务人员花费大量时间。他们阻塞了系统。他们耗费了数百万美元。他们是一个巨大的管理问题。药物对这种障碍无效，心理分析只会让他们情况更糟。他们太不稳定了。
There is a new program to deal with them, and it's getting some results. But unfortunately, it goes against some of the basic rules of prison life. In particular, it goes against the rule that everybody in prison should get treated the same. Gregory Warner went to Springfield, Missouri, to check out the program, to the oldest and largest prison hospital in the country.
有一个新的项目来处理他们，并取得了一些成果。但不幸的是，这违反了监狱生活的一些基本规则。特别是，它违背了监狱里每个人都应得到相同对待的规则。Gregory Warner 前往密苏里州的斯普林菲尔德，去查看这个项目，那里是全国历史最悠久、规模最大的监狱医院。
It's more prison than hospital, the United States Medical Center for Federal Prisoners. It was built in 1933, back when they were still designing prisons to look like fortresses. It stands alone in a huge field like something that should be approached on horseback.
这里与其说是医院，不如说是监狱，是联邦囚犯医疗中心。它建于 1933 年，当时他们设计监狱时还把它看作堡垒。它孤零零地矗立在一片巨大的平原上，就像那种需要骑马接近的东西。
Inside are some of the more advanced medical services for inmates in the country: a dialysis unit, a cancer ward. But there's still a feel of the prison stockade: bars, guard stations, a wheelchair-accessible chow hall. Another building houses the mental health ward. A few people in Springfield, even the guy who rented my car at the airport, warned me about running into Hannibal Lecter here. But inside the prison, the mention of Hannibal gets only an embarrassed shrug.
里面拥有全国一些最先进的囚犯医疗服务：透析单元、癌症病房。但这里依然有一种监狱围栏的感觉：铁栏杆、警卫哨所、残疾人无障碍食堂。另一栋建筑设有心理健康病房。斯普林菲尔德的少数几个人，甚至在机场给我租车的家伙，都警告过我在这里会遇到汉尼拔·莱克特。但在监狱里，提到汉尼拔只会得到一个尴尬的耸肩。
The controversial inmates are on the third floor in the unlocked unit for inmates with Borderline Personality Disorder, some of the most problematic inmates in the entire federal prison system. The unit is surprisingly calm, given these guys' histories. Unless there's a therapy group in session, we find the men clustered around card tables or reading, or just pacing down the narrow corridor. The whole unit is one L-shaped hallway with brooms and cells off of that.
那些有争议的囚犯住在三楼的非封闭单元，专门关押患有边缘性人格障碍的囚犯，他们是整个联邦监狱系统中最麻烦的囚犯中的一部分。考虑到这些家伙的历史，这个单元出奇地平静。除非正在进行治疗小组活动，否则我们发现男人们围在牌桌旁或看书，或者只是沿着狭窄的走廊踱步。整个单元是一个 L 型的走廊，旁边有杂物间和牢房。
This is where I find Randy Nielsen, 45 years old, he's been in for bank robbery since he was 19. He's tall with graying hair and shining gray eyes. The scars on his arms actually overlap, new scars on top of old ones, from all the times he's tried to hurt himself.
我就是在这里找到了 45 岁的 Randy Nielsen，他从 19 岁起就因银行抢劫入狱。他个子很高，头发花白，眼神明亮而灰暗。他手臂上的伤疤实际上是重叠的，新伤疤覆盖着旧伤疤，这都是他多次试图伤害自己的痕迹。
I never knew what was wrong with me. And I really thought I was crazy because I would have crying fits in the middle of-- in a chow hall or walking, and somebody would be talking, and then all of a sudden, I'd just start screaming and pulling my hair and beating my face until they sedated me.
我从来不知道自己有什么问题。我真的以为自己疯了，因为我会在食堂中间——或者走路时突然歇斯底里地哭起来，当有人说话时，突然之间，我就开始尖叫、扯头发、打自己的脸，直到他们给我镇静剂。
And why do you think you were doing that?
那你觉得你为什么要那样做？
I got attention. And they had to deal with me. One way or the other, they had to deal with me.
我得到了关注。他们必须处理我。不管怎样，他们都必须处理我。
They've learned that that's the only reason and the only way that people will listen to them, is if everything is a crisis.
他们已经学会了，那是人们听他们说话的唯一原因和唯一方式，就是让每一件事都变成危机。
Keith Smith is a treatment specialist who works with Nielsen and the other guys on this unit.
Keith Smith 是一位治疗专家，他和 Nielsen 以及这个单元里的其他人一起工作。
Every headache that he might get, that's a tumor. Every ache and pain, that's a broken joint or cancer or something horrible. He needs very expensive tests. He needs them right now. So today, you might go through a huge ordeal to get him seen for one thing, and you think it's passed. And then the next day, it's something totally different. Same crisis, new ailment.
他可能出现的每一个头痛，那都是肿瘤。每一个酸痛，那都是骨折或是癌症什么的恐怖东西。他需要非常昂贵的测试。他现在就要做。所以今天，你可能会经历巨大的磨难让他为一件事进行检查，你以为事情过去了。然后第二天，又是完全不同的情况。同样的危机，新的疾病。
What makes people with Borderline Personality Disorder so difficult to deal with is they can be incredibly hostile and manipulative, and at the same time, phenomenally needy. They crave attention and approval. They can't deal with people, but they can't bear to be alone, and they fear being abandoned. And the littlest things can throw them into a crisis, someone not saying hello in the hallway, or not getting the right amount of food. And once they're upset, they're uncontrollable. They'll mutilate themselves if they don't get their way. They'll threaten suicide, and they'll mean it for as long as the crisis lasts.
边缘性人格障碍患者之所以如此难处理，是因为他们可能极其敌对和操纵，同时又极其需要他人。他们渴望关注和认可。他们无法与人相处，但又无法忍受孤独，他们害怕被抛弃。哪怕最微小的事情也能让他们陷入危机，比如走廊里有人没跟他打招呼，或者饭菜份量给得不对。一旦他们心烦意乱，他们就无法控制。如果他们达不到目的，他们就会自残。他们会威胁自杀，而且只要危机持续，他们就是当真的。
In prison, they start fights and sew drama. They attempt suicide, and then sue the prison for rescuing them. Generally, prison has two ways of dealing with these inmates. They can transfer them to a new facility with the idea that a change of scenery might change the behavior, a temporary solution that works often enough there's even an unofficial term for it: diesel therapy. Or they could use punishment to deter the behavior: solitary confinement. The hole, it's called.
在监狱里，他们挑起争斗，制造事端。他们尝试自杀，然后起诉监狱救援他们。通常，监狱有两种处理这些囚犯的方法。他们可以将他们转移到新的设施，认为换个环境可能会改变行为，这是一种暂时的解决方案，效果经常好到甚至有一个非官方的术语：柴油疗法。或者他们可以使用惩罚来遏制这种行为：单独监禁。也就是所谓的“黑洞”。
But diesel therapy is expensive and only works temporarily. And the hole for borderlines can often exacerbate the symptoms. Mostly, prisons don't know what to do.
但柴油疗法昂贵且只能暂时有效。而对于边缘型人格患者来说，黑洞往往会加剧症状。大多数情况下，监狱不知道该怎么办。
They are exhausting. They are difficult. They wear you out.
他们令人筋疲力尽。他们很麻烦。他们让你心力交瘁。
This is psychologist Georgina Ashlock. Two years ago, the Federal Bureau of Prisons hired her to launch the experimental program here in Springfield to stop borderline inmates from mutilating themselves or attempting suicide. It's a daunting task. She didn't have much competition landing the job. Only one other psychologist in the entire Bureau of Prisons applied for it.
这是心理学家 Georgina Ashlock。两年前，联邦监狱管理局聘请她在斯普林菲尔德启动这个实验项目，以阻止边缘型囚犯自残或自杀。这是一项艰巨的任务。她在获得这份工作时没遇到太多竞争。在整个联邦监狱管理局中，只有另外一名心理学家申请了这份工作。
Why would anybody be motivated to want to take on one or two, let alone 48, individuals who are at high risk of killing themselves or mutilating themselves and who absolutely wear you out day to day as you try to facilitate change?
为什么有人会愿意承担一个或两个，更不用说 48 个有自杀或自残高风险，且在你试图促进改变时让你每天都精疲力竭的人？
So the experimental program that Dr. Ashlock started uses a treatment called DBT: Dialectical Behavior Therapy. DBT was developed in the '90s, and it's still the only treatment that's ever shown to work on borderlines. What it  is, it tries to stop borderline behavior by teaching them techniques to deal with emotions, skills like breathing deeply to relax, or keeping an emotion diary to gain self-awareness.
所以 Ashlock 博士启动的实验项目使用了一种叫 DBT 的治疗方法：辩证行为疗法。DBT 开发于 90 年代，至今仍是唯一被证明对边缘型人格患者有效的疗法。它的作用是，通过教他们处理情绪的技巧来阻止边缘行为，比如深度呼吸来放松，或写情绪日记以增强自我意识。
Because mostly this disorder is diagnosed in women, a lot of the skills are specific to women, like taking a bubble bath or painting your nails. The worksheets had to be modified for men, of course, and Ashlock said modified further for men in prison.
因为这种障碍大多在女性中诊断出来，所以很多技巧是专门针对女性的，比如泡泡浴或涂指甲。当然，工作表必须针对男性进行修改，Ashlock 说还要为监狱里的男性进一步修改。
You cannot say drive in the countryside and look at the leaves, the autumn leaves, or go see a movie, or even one of the suggestions on one of the handouts is something like you can sit in the lobby of a hotel, you know, maybe a historic hotel or building or something and look at the surroundings. So adapting, helping them discover what they do have access to, that's a challenge.
你不能建议在乡间开车看树叶，看秋叶，或者去看电影，甚至讲义上的建议之一是像坐在酒店大厅，你知道，也许是历史酒店或建筑什么的，看看周围环境。所以，帮助他们发现他们能接触到什么是项挑战。
What prisoners do have access to are things like photos ripped from magazines of puppies or beaches to focus on. They have rubber bands to snap on their wrists when they feel like cutting. And they also have the distraction of the weight room.
囚犯们能接触到的是从杂志上撕下来的小狗或海滩照片，用这些来专注。他们有橡皮筋，想割伤自己时可以弹在手腕上。他们还可以利用举重室来分散注意力。
DBT also teaches interpersonal skills, like how to ask a nurse for aspirin. A lot of these guys have no idea. They'll demand aspirin, and the nurse will tell them to wait, and then they'll start screaming, and the whole situation just escalates. They don't get the aspirin, and they get thrown in the hall for making a scene. So DBT has all this worksheets on how to break the interaction down, like how badly do I want to aspirin? Does the nurse have any aspirin? Is she really busy? Or is she in a giving mood? And what's the body language of someone in a giving mood?
DBT 还教授人际交往技能，比如如何向护士要阿司匹林。很多家伙对此一窍不通。他们会索要阿司匹林，护士叫他们等一下，他们就开始尖叫，整个局面随之升级。他们没拿到阿司匹林，还因为闹事被扔进了黑洞。所以 DBT 有很多如何分解互动的工作表，比如：我有多想要阿司匹林？护士有阿司匹林吗？她现在是不是很忙？还是她心情好？心情好的人的肢体语言是什么样的？
DBT is like a Berlitz guide to dealing with the world. As basic as all this seems, Ashlock says these are skills that these guys never learned, in large part because of abusive childhoods. And all these little skills add up. You learn how to ask for aspirin, people see you as a nice person. Your personality begins to change. Even the big things can start shifting, like one's ability to empathize with others. But sometimes that can cause more problems in prison, where being a nice guy can be seen as a sign of weakness. Acting reasonably can be difficult or even dangerous.
DBT 就像是一本应对世界的 Berlitz 指南。尽管这一切看起来很基础，Ashlock 说这些是这些家伙从未学过的技能，很大程度上是因为他们遭受过虐待的童年。而所有这些小技巧加起来就有了效果。你学会了如何要阿司匹林，人们就会把你当作一个好人。你的人格开始发生变化。即使是重大的事情也可能开始转变，比如对他人的共情能力。但有时这会在监狱里造成更多问题，在那里，做一个好人可能被视为软弱的标志。表现得理智可能很困难，甚至很危险。
It's hard to live in this environment and actually go by these rules. But you want to because you're actually trying to better yourself.
在这种环境中生活并真正遵循这些规则很难。但你想要这样做，因为你真的在努力完善自己。
This is Edwin Torres. He's 33 and has served two years of a 20-year sentence for drug dealing.
这是 Edwin Torres。他 33 岁，因贩毒被判 20 年监禁，已经服刑两年。
Can you give me an example of a time when you faced that pressure?
你能给我举一个你面临这种压力的例子吗？
Sure. I had a problem not too long ago, actually. I was arguing with a guy in recreation. I came back to the unit because I was so mad. Normally, I would have just fought with the guy right there. But I was so mad and I'm thinking about the program, so I just walked away from the guy while we were arguing. I just said-- you know, I just walked away, didn't even say nothing to him. I walked all the way back to the unit, sat in the unit for, like, three or four minutes. And then I decided, you know what? I'm going to go back. Whatever happens happens.
当然。不久前我确实遇到了问题。我在娱乐活动时和一个家伙争吵。我回到单元，因为我太生气了。正常情况下，我当时就会和他打架。但我太生气了，我想到了这个项目，所以我就在争吵时离开了那个家伙。我只是说——你知道，我只是走开了，什么都没对他说。我一直走回单元，在单元里坐了大概三四分钟。然后我决定，你知道吗？我要回去。无论发生什么就发生吧。
And I'm fighting myself all the way down the hallway. And then I didn't even get back to recreation. By the time I'm halfway there, I see my buddies coming. And they're like, you know what? It ain't worth it. He ain't worth it. Remember, you can't make decisions in an emotional mind and just-- and I was, like, you know what? It actually made me happy. I started laughing. I'm like, man, guys, thanks a lot for you guys being here. You really helped me out.
我一路走回走廊时都在跟自己斗争。然后我甚至没回到娱乐室。走到半路，我看到我的伙伴们过来了。他们说，你知道吗？这不值得。他不值得。记住，你不能在情绪化的心智中做决定，然后——我当时想，你知道吗？这确实让我很开心。我开始笑了。我说，伙计们，谢谢你们在这里。你们真的帮了我。
The inmates throw these terms around. Emotional mind, which refers to an excited emotional state, versus wise mind, which is more balanced. A lot of DBT jargon derives from Eastern philosophy. Here's C.J., a 31-year-old inmate.
囚犯们经常使用这些术语。情绪化心智，指一种亢奋的情绪状态，相对的是理智心智，更加平衡。很多 DBT 的术语源于东方哲学。这是 C.J.，一名 31 岁的囚犯。
You know, they got a skill here called radical acceptance. You've just got to accept what the situation is. I'm in prison. These cops have their job. The other inmates are going to do what they're going to do. Because I let little things just work me up. But if I can just look at the thing and laugh and say, wow, that's not a big deal at all, man, then I just radically accept the situation. I know I can't change it. It's just the way it is. And then it just passes for the moment.
你知道，这里有一种技巧叫“彻底接纳”。你必须接受现状。我在监狱里。这些警察有他们的工作。其他囚犯做他们该做的事。因为我让小事让我心烦意乱。但如果我能审视这件事并笑笑，说，哇，这根本没什么大不了，伙计，那么我就是彻底接纳了这种情况。我知道我无法改变它。事实就是这样。然后那一刻就过去了。
My interview with C.J. had been rescheduled at the last minute. And in the past, he told me that would have spun him out of control, ruined his whole day. This time, he knew what to do. He went back to his cell and did the things he knew would calm himself down. He made coffee. He changed his shoes. He used his skills.
我对 C.J. 的采访在最后一刻被重新安排了。过去，他告诉我那会让他失去控制，毁掉他的一整天。这一次，他知道该怎么做。他回到牢房，做了他知道能让自己平静下来的事情。他冲了咖啡。他换了鞋子。他运用了他的技巧。
The DBT program's only two years old, and most of the success is anecdotal, but the initial statistics are promising. Out of 21 inmates who finished at least half the program, suicide attempts are down by 94%. And the same inmates are spending 73% less time in the hole. And this is after they leave the program or they go to a new prison.
DBT 项目才开展两年，大部分成功都是轶事证据，但初步统计数字令人振奋。在完成至少一半项目的 21 名囚犯中，自杀企图减少了 94%。同一批囚犯在“黑洞”中的时间减少了 73%。这是在他们离开项目或前往新监狱之后的情况。
But that doesn't mean all the prison staff is happy with the program, because the operative word in Dialectical Behavior Therapy is behavior. And for it to work, the therapists have to be involved in deciding how misbehavior is punished. And this brings them directly in conflict with the guards, who traditionally have control over that. So DBT has set off a turf war between the corrections staff and the therapists.
但这并不意味着所有监狱工作人员都对该项目感到满意，因为辩证行为疗法的关键词是“行为”。为了使其生效，治疗师必须参与决定如何惩罚不当行为。这直接导致他们与狱警发生冲突，狱警传统上对此有控制权。所以 DBT 引发了矫正人员和治疗师之间的地盘之争。
For instance, sending prisoners to the hole is one of the main tools the corrections staff has as a form of punishment. But under DBT, Dr. Ashlock can actually take an inmate out of a hole. That's a pretty big deal. And she also allows the inmates to voluntarily place themselves in the hole if they feel like it's the only way they can get control of themselves. Instead of acting out to get there, they can just go, like taking a sick day for work. Guards hate all this special treatment.
例如，将囚犯送入黑洞是矫正人员惩罚的主要手段之一。但在 DBT 下，Ashlock 博士实际上可以把囚犯带出黑洞。这可是件大事。她还允许囚犯如果觉得那是自己获得控制权的唯一方法，可以自愿进入黑洞。他们不需要通过制造事端来进去，他们可以直接去，就像请病假一样。狱警讨厌这种特殊待遇。
Dr. Ashlock tells me this story about an inmate who attempted suicide. Normal procedure is that the prison guards would strip him and place him in a suicide cell. But Dr. Ashlock spoke to him and decided that the suicide cell wasn't the best place for him.
Ashlock 博士告诉我一个关于一名囚犯尝试自杀的故事。正常程序是监狱看守会脱掉他的衣服把他关进自杀监控牢房。但 Ashlock 博士和他谈过话，认为自杀监控牢房对他来说并不是最好的地方。
Well, it was very obvious with talking with him that the crisis had passed. So I made a decision clinically that he could return to the semi-locked unit. Oh my God. You would have thought that we had taken the guy out for a steak dinner and bought him a plane ticket home. I mean, the institution went crazy. And they were calling the union, saying just what a stupid decision that was, and that I rewarded his behavior, and that it wasn't safe, and that he should have been, at the minimum, punished by being placed in a stripped cell overnight. It was completely ridiculous, and it was just so destructive to the whole treatment milieu that I ultimately had to ship the inmate out. I mean, it was over. It was just over. There was so much controversy, so much heated emotion about it that it was impossible to even keep the inmate there and continue to work together.
嗯，跟他的谈话显然表明危机已经过去。所以我从临床角度做了一个决定，让他回到非封闭单元。哦我的天。你肯定会以为我们带那个家伙去吃了一顿牛排大餐并给他买了一张回家的机票。我的意思是，整个机构都疯了。他们给工会打电话，说那是一个多么愚蠢的决定，说我奖励了他的行为，说那不安全，说他至少应该通过被关进空牢房一夜来受到惩罚。这太荒谬了，而且对整个治疗环境具有破坏性，我最终不得不把那个囚犯转走了。我的意思是，结束了。彻底结束了。有太多的争议，太多的激烈情绪，以至于根本无法让那个囚犯留在那儿继续合作。
Many of these guys are here for being manipulative criminals, master manipulators.
这些家伙中的许多人是因为作为操纵性罪犯——犯罪大师——而被关在这里的。
Larry Caudle has been a corrections officer at Springfield for 13 years and was president of the guards' union when the DBT program was introduced. He says in prison you have to be suspicious of everything to protect your own safety, and you're trained to resist inmates who want to manipulate you.
Larry Caudle 在斯普林菲尔德做狱警已经 13 年了，当 DBT 项目引入时，他是狱警工会的主席。他说在监狱里你必须怀疑一切以保护自己的安全，你受过培训要抵制想要操纵你的囚犯。
A lot of them have learned that sometimes if you can't get what you want by verbalizing a problem, stick a pencil in your arm. Somebody's going to listen. Throw a fit. Scream, cuss, carry on like a little kid. Threaten to kill somebody. Somebody will listen to you. That's how a lot of staff view it, that people come here, they get out of a penitentiary where they have problems. They play the game for a year. And a lot of times, if they're really successful, they eventually get their custody level downgraded, and they go to a little bit less restrictive, a less dangerous place. And a lot of staff feel like that they're just manipulating the system.
他们中的许多人已经学会了，有时如果通过语言无法解决问题，就把铅笔插进手臂里。总会有人听的。发脾气。尖叫、咒骂、像个小孩一样胡闹。威胁要杀人。总会有人听你的。这就是很多工作人员的看法，人们来到这里，走出监狱时遇到问题。他们玩了一年的游戏。很多时候，如果他们真的很成功，他们最终会降级监禁水平，被转移到限制较少、危险较小的地方。很多工作人员觉得他们只是在操纵系统。
It all just looks wrong, one officer told me. Even the idea of calling inmates "patients" sends some guards into a cussing fit. They're not there to help cure anyone. They're there to keep control.
这一切看起来都不对劲，一名警官告诉我。甚至把囚犯称为“病人”这个想法都会让一些狱警咒骂起来。他们在这里不是为了帮助治愈任何人。他们在这里是为了维持秩序。
The prison anticipated trouble from officers even before the DBT program started. So they launched a Hearts and Minds campaign to convince officers that DBT would help them control inmates. There was a DBT role-play at the annual staff training, but the message wasn't getting through. The officers asked Dr. Ashlock if the inmates would get flowered curtains and pizza parties. They told another therapist to expect gladiator battles and daily rapes.
监狱在 DBT 项目开始前就已经预料到狱警会制造麻烦。所以他们发起了“人心计划”，试图说服狱警 DBT 能帮助他们管理囚犯。在年度员工培训中进行了 DBT 的角色扮演，但信息并没有传达下去。狱警们问 Ashlock 博士囚犯们会不会得到带花窗帘和披萨派对。他们告诉另一位治疗师，准备好角斗士的战斗和每日的强奸吧。
So then the prison set up a special website with a thing called an Ask-It Basket, where Dr. Ashlock would field anonymous questions to dispel the various rumors, but that just led to more hostility. Officers basically accused Ashlock of tossing out misbehavior reports to make the program look good and said the program was just a cozy hideout for inmates to go masturbate. The Ask-It Basket was shut down after two weeks.
所以监狱建立了一个特殊的网站，有一个叫“提问篮”的东西，Ashlock 博士会在那里匿名回答问题以消除各种谣言，但这只导致了更多的敌意。狱警们基本上指责 Ashlock 扔掉不当行为报告来美化项目，说该项目只是囚犯们去自慰的温馨藏身处。“提问篮”在两周后被关闭。
Keith Smith has seen both sides of this argument. He was an officer in the prison, and then he became a treatment specialist in the DBT program. And ever since he took the job, his best officer friends won't talk to him. They stopped going bowling with him on Friday nights, and their families don't get together anymore.
Keith Smith 看到了争论的双方。他曾是监狱的狱警，后来成了 DBT 项目的治疗专家。自从他接手这份工作，他最好的狱警朋友就不再和他说话了。他们不再在周五晚上和他一起打保龄球，他们的家人也不再聚在一起了。
A lot of officers see you as either you're with the officers or you're with the inmates. So if you take any kind of a position where you're not directly, absolutely against the inmate, you're for them. And that means giving them special favors or being soft on them, not calling them on their incidents or not writing incident reports, things of that nature, letting them get away with things that you shouldn't.
很多警官把你视为要么你站在狱警这边，要么站在囚犯那边。所以如果你采取任何一种立场，即你不直接、绝对地反对囚犯，你就是站在他们那边的。这意味着给予他们特殊的优待，或者对他们心软，不报告他们的事件或不写事故报告，这类事情，让他们逃脱他们不该逃脱的事情。
Dr. Ashlock doesn't see what the big deal is. She thinks officers should be in favor of a program that helps them handle these inmates, that leads to fewer outbursts and less violence. She says what the officers don't understand is that by giving these prisoners special treatment, by bending the rules for them, she's not giving into their manipulation, she's trying to stop it. She tells the story of an inmate who swallowed a piece of razor blade and was sent to the hole. And then she discovered that he did that so he could avoid guys he owed gambling debts to.
Ashlock 博士不明白这有什么大不了的。她认为狱警应该支持一个帮助他们应对这些囚犯、从而减少爆发和暴力的项目。她说狱警们不明白的是，通过给予这些囚犯特殊待遇，通过为他们变通规则，她并不是在屈服于他们的操纵，她是在努力阻止它。她讲了一个囚犯吞下一片剃须刀片并被送进黑洞的故事。然后她发现他这样做是为了躲避他欠下赌债的家伙。
I immediately took him out of lockup. Same kind of thing. Backlash, people appalled. Oh, she's rewarding his behavior, and she's not doing what she said she was going to do in the program. But they did not understand that that was what the inmate wanted, was to hide in lockup. And we came in and said you're coming out. We brought him to my office and said you're going to figure out who you owe and how much you owe. You're going to go meet with those inmates on the compound. You're going to work out a plan for repayment. You're going to face your situation that you created.
我立即把他从隔离室带了出来。同样的事情。反弹，人们感到震惊。噢，她在奖励他的行为，而且她没有按照她在项目中承诺的那样做。但他们不明白，那正是那个囚犯想要的——躲进隔离室。我们走进去说你得出来。我们把他带到我的办公室，告诉他你得搞清楚你欠谁的，欠多少。你要去和院子里的那些囚犯见面。你要制定一个还款计划。你要面对你自己创造的局面。
Now, did that inmate stop racking up debts? No, because this is a very long pattern of behavior for him. However, we certainly took away his motivation to use self-harm to avoid that responsibility. So to me, it seems like a very simple solution.
现在，那个囚犯停止继续欠债了吗？没有，因为这对他来说是一种非常长期的行为模式。然而，我们肯定剥夺了他利用自残来逃避责任的动机。所以对我来说，这似乎是一个非常简单的解决方案。
The problem is, when a prisoner mutilates himself or tries to kill himself, the guards see it one way, the therapists see it another. There's a jail in Kentucky that reportedly uses something officers call the fingernail test to tell the difference between a real suicide attempt and a manipulative one. The officer basically uses his fingernail to measure if the wound is deep enough to be a real suicide. That's a pretty gross example, but it's an issue that every prison struggles with it and that's at the heart of this disagreement. No one wants a suicide on their watch, but no one wants to be sucker either.
问题在于，当囚犯自残或尝试自杀时，狱警看是一种方式，治疗师看是另一种方式。据报道，肯塔基州有一所监狱使用警官称之为“指甲测试”的方法来区分真正的自杀企图和操纵性的自杀企图。警官基本上用他的指甲来测量伤口是否深到足以成为真正的自杀。这是一个相当恶心的例子，但这是每所监狱都在挣扎的问题，也是这种分歧的核心。没有人希望在自己的值班时间发生自杀，但也没有人想被当作傻瓜。
Gregory Warner lives in New York. Coming up, mommy knows best, but sometimes she needs the power that comes with cassette tape. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
Gregory Warner 住在纽约。接下来，妈妈最懂，但有时她需要磁带带来的力量。一分钟后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This  American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Special Treatment. We have stories about the pros and cons of not treating everyone the same.
这是《美国生活》。我是 Ira Glass。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题：特殊待遇。我们有关于不平等待人利弊的故事。
We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Mommy's Psychic Helper.
我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，《妈妈的通灵助手》。
When Aimee and Andrew were babies in Southern California, their Vietnamese mom got their horoscopes done by a fortune teller, and had them recorded onto a cassette tape.
当 Aimee 和 Andrew 在南加州还是婴儿时，他们的越南妈妈请算命师为他们算了星座运势，并把它们录在了一盘磁带上。
She listened to this tape all the time.
她一直都在听这盘磁带。
She did?
真的吗？
Uh-huh. At one point, she had three jobs, and it was really stressful for her. And we would be upstairs going to bed, getting ready for bed, and she would sit in the living room, and she would listen to the tape sometimes. And if we would go downstairs, sometimes I would hear her listening to the tape, just her sitting, usually lying down.
嗯。有段时间，她有三份工作，这让她压力很大。我们要么在楼上准备睡觉，要么准备上床，她就会坐在客厅，有时听着磁带。如果我们下楼，有时我会听到她在听磁带，她自己坐着，通常是躺着。
[SPEAKING VIETNAMESE]
[越南语]
It became a part of our everyday for her to talk about these tapes whenever she would be talking about our personalities. But since Andrew and I can't understand Vietnamese very well, it was just this voice. It was just this deep voice, very somber voice.
每当她谈论我们的个性时，谈论这些磁带成了我们日常生活的一部分。但因为 Andrew 和我不太懂越南语，那只是一道声音。只是一道深沉的声音，非常忧郁的声音。
[SPEAKING VIETNAMESE]
[越南语]
The fortune's content would change with her attitude sometimes.
算命的内容有时会随着她的态度而改变。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
What parts of the fortune would happen in what mood?
算命的哪些部分会在什么情绪下出现？
Well, when she was in a good mood, when she was happy, she would talk about how the fortune said how smart and clever I was, and how independent I was going to be, and how much I'd travel. And whenever the credit card bills would come in and my mom would find out how much she thought I was spending, she would say how much money I wasted, and how the fortune had warned her that I was going to be a money waster, and if I wasn't careful, I would be broke for the rest of my life. And even now-- I haven't lived at home for eight years-- even now when the bills come home, my dad will say that she still blames me.
嗯，当她心情好时，她开心时，她会谈论算命怎么说我有多聪明、多伶俐，我会有多独立，我以后会去旅行多少地方。每当信用卡账单寄来，我妈发现她觉得我花掉的钱时，她就会说我浪费了多少钱，算命是怎么警告过她我会是个浪费钱的人，如果不小心，我下半辈子都会身无分文。即使是现在——我已经八年没住家里了——即使是现在账单寄来，我爸还是会说她仍然在怪我。
And do you use their credit card?
你会用他们的信用卡吗？
Never.
从来不用。
Wait. And she still gets the credit card bill, and then she goes, like, that Aimee?
等等。她还是收到信用卡账单，然后她就会说，是 Aimee 干的？
Right. I think I was actually really sensible about money, but I did feel this guilt every month.
是的。我觉得我在钱方面其实很理智，但我确实每个月都感到这种内疚。
So basically, all your life, you've been haunted by this idea that you're really terrible with money and you're spending too much money. Can I just run something from the fortune by you?
所以基本上，你一辈子都被这种想法困扰，觉得你在钱方面真的很糟糕，你花了太多的钱。我可以把算命里的一些话念给你听吗？
OK.
好的。
So we had a translator translate this, and we have some recordings of her, and then some parts of this I'm just going to read to you.
我们找了个翻译把它翻译出来了，我们有她的一些录音，然后这里面的一些部分我直接念给你听。
OK.
好的。
It says right here, talking about characteristics, you are loquacious and disgruntled, which will cause you back pain. You will be a good treasurer-- which I think means good with money-- and quickly become a wealthy person. And then here's the translator.
这里写着，谈到性格特征，你多嘴又爱抱怨，这会导致你背痛。你将成为一名出色的财务主管——我想这意味着擅长理财——并很快成为富有的人。这是翻译。
[SPEAKING VIETNAMESE]
[越南语]
The five years after 49, she will be very rich.
49 岁之后的五年里，她会非常富有。
Oh my gosh! So all the money stuff isn't in there. Like, it doesn't say I'm going to waste money. I've never heard that fortune. Maybe she was scared to tell me that.
天哪！所以所有关于钱的东西都不在里面。它根本没说我会浪费钱。我从没听过那样的算命。也许她不敢告诉我。
OK, Aimee. I have another clip of tape of the translator to play you. I hope you're ready for this.
好了，Aimee。我还有一段翻译的磁带要放给你听。希望你准备好了。
OK.
好的。
[SPEAKING VIETNAMESE]
[越南语]
The reason why I laughed is that she will be very chubby in these years.
我笑的原因是，她这几年会变得非常胖。
What years?
什么几年？
She must be on diet because too fat.
她必须节食，因为太胖了。
Oh my God! See, this is the thing. My mom's always warning me about being chubby, too.
天哪！你看，就是这件事。我妈也总是警告我要变胖。
She is?
她警告你？
And I'm not chubby! I'm not chubby. And the thing in Vietnamese culture is you're always putting more food on people's plates, right? This is the thing. You have to eat more. You have to eat more. It's like the custom. She stopped doing that and that really hurt me. But Andrew's never had a problem with his weight. He never looks bad. He never has to be watched over for that kind of stuff.
我又不胖！我不胖。越南文化中的一点就是你总是往人们的盘子里堆更多的食物，对吧？就是这样。你必须多吃点。你必须多吃点。这就像习俗。她不再那样做了，那真的伤害了我。但 Andrew 从来没有体重问题。他看起来从来都不糟。他从来不需要因为那种事被看管。
Wait. Are you saying that you actually believe in the fortune?
等等。你是说你其实相信算命？
Honestly, I don't know. Sometimes I wonder if that horoscope didn't exist I would maybe be different. I wouldn't have problems with money. I wouldn't have problems with work and in making decisions in my life. I know Andrew's horoscope said he was going to be very hard-working. He was going to be like Confucius, very slow and steady, and work very hard for his life, and he would have a good life. And part of me was kind of jealous of that, the fact that his fate seemed to be happier than mine.
老实说，我不知道。有时我怀疑，如果那个星座运势不存在，我也许会变得不一样。我不会有钱方面的问题。我不会在工作和生活决策中遇到问题。我知道 Andrew 的星座运势说他会非常努力工作。他会像孔子一样，非常缓慢稳健，一生非常努力地工作，他会过上好生活。我内心的一部分其实有点嫉妒那个，嫉妒他的命运看起来比我快乐。
Aimee Phan has just missed four student loan payments. Her brother Andrew is in medical school, as his horoscope predicted. Aimee has a book of short stories called We Should Never Meet. That will be published by St. Martin's Press in September.
Aimee Phan 刚刚错过了四次学生贷款还款。她哥哥 Andrew 正在医学院学习，正如他的星座运势所预言的那样。Aimee 有一本短篇小说集叫《We Should Never Meet》。这本书将于九月由圣马丁出版社出版。
Act Four, The Way to a Boy's Heart is Through His Stomach.
第四幕，《男孩的心是通过胃抓住的》。
Lisa Carver's son was born with a rare chromosomal disorder, and one of the things that it does to him is that his throat does not function properly. The biggest problem it causes is this: he can't eat at all. He has to be fed in a special way. And that's just where his special treatment begins. His name's Wolfgang. He's nine and a half. Here's Lisa.
Lisa Carver 的儿子出生时患有一种罕见的染色体疾病，它对他造成的影响之一就是他的喉咙功能不正常。它导致的最大问题是：他根本无法进食。他必须以一种特殊的方式进食。而这仅仅是他特殊待遇的开始。他的名字叫 Wolfgang。他九岁半。这是 Lisa。
At first, they hoped that eventually he would eat, and so they wanted him to know how to eat, and they wanted the sensory experience of eating to stimulate talking. And so he would have tastes of different foods in really small amounts, all different kinds of foods, and he just loved all food. He never rejected any kind of food. but he kept on getting pneumonias, and so we did a swallow study where they let him swallow something and take an x-ray of his throat, and they saw that a small amount of every bite, just maybe 1/10 of it, was going down into his lungs because his epiglottis wasn't closing correctly or fully over the part of the esophagus that goes to the lungs.
起初，他们希望最终他会进食，所以他们想让他知道怎么进食，他们想要进食的感官体验来刺激语言。所以他会尝一点点不同种类的食物，份量很小，各种各样的食物，他简直热爱所有食物。他从不排斥任何食物。但他一直患肺炎，所以我们做了吞咽研究，让他们让他吞咽一些东西并给他的喉咙拍 X 光片，他们发现每一口食物里有少量，也许只有十分之一，进入了他的肺部，因为他的会厌没有正确或完全关闭覆盖住通往肺部的食管部分。
Now he eats nothing, and he drinks nothing. Every once in awhile, when there's a holiday, he'll chew on some stuff for fun and social pleasure, and then he'll spit it out into a napkin. So he's NPO. That means nothing by mouth. I don't know what it actually stands for, but that's for life.
现在他什么都不吃，什么都不喝。偶尔在节假日，他会咀嚼一些东西来寻求乐趣和社交满足感，然后把它吐进餐巾纸里。所以他是 NPO。这意味着禁食。我不知道这实际上代表什么，但那是终生的。
I think it was harder on him when he was having tastes of things because it would get him all excited. And now that he doesn't have anything, he's more accepting, but it just doesn't die. It's like he still remembers what things taste like. And people eat all the time. I never realized how much people eat until I had a kid who couldn't eat, who was looking at me eat. But he wants it all the time, and it's all around, always. It's always there.
我想他在能尝东西时其实更难受，因为那会让他兴奋。现在他什么都没有了，他更接受了，但那种渴望并没有消失。就好像他仍然记得东西的味道。人们一直在进食。我以前从没意识到人们进食有多频繁，直到我有一个不能吃东西、只能看着我吃的孩子。但他一直想要，而且食物就在周围，一直都有。它总是存在的。
You are about to hear the sound of every child but one at the elementary school down the road having lunch.
你马上要听到街那头的小学里除了一个孩子外所有孩子吃午餐的声音。
[SOUNDS OF CHILDREN IN THE LUNCHROOM]
[食堂里孩子的声音]
The school that he's at now, they've always been just really caring about Wolf. When there's a birthday party, they have toys and stickers and games without the usual cupcakes and food creations. And when they made gingerbread houses for Christmas, they didn't use gingerbread and marshmallows and jelly beans. They used art materials that looked like those things.
他现在上的那所学校，他们一直非常关心 Wolf。当有生日聚会时，他们有玩具、贴纸和游戏，而没有通常的纸杯蛋糕和食物创作。当他们为圣诞节制作姜饼屋时，他们没有用姜饼、棉花糖和软糖。他们用了看起来像那些东西的美术材料。
And now we're on our way down the hall to where the one child has his lunch. And at lunch, when all the kids go down to the cafeteria, Wolf goes to his own private decorated cafeteria, which is in the health office.
现在我们沿着走廊走去，去那个只有一个孩子吃午餐的地方。午餐时间，当所有孩子去食堂时，Wolf 去他自己私人的装饰过的食堂，那是在卫生室里。
Hello!
你好！
Hello! Hi, Wolf!
你好！嘿，Wolf！
When it's time for Wolf to have a meal, he lifts up his shirt, and there's his little plastic G-tube, which is about three inches to the left of his belly button. And it's like a little plastic valve with a button on it or a snap, sort of like your gas tank has that little cover. And you take the cover off, and somebody puts the long skinny tube into the little hole, and pours the food down the long skinny tube. And it's sort of a creamy color, and it goes down like that, and his meal is done.
当 Wolf 该进餐时，他掀起衬衫，那里有他的小塑料胃管，离他肚脐左侧大约三英寸。那就像一个带有按钮或扣子的小塑料阀门，就像你的油箱有那个小盖子一样。你把盖子拿下来，有人把那根长细管放进那个小孔里，把食物顺着长细管倒进去。它是那种奶油色的，它就这样流下去，然后他的饭就吃完了。
OK. Good, good.
好的。很好，很好。
This room where Wolf eats is decorated with all the things that Wolf loves, mainly caterpillars and aliens. There's a couple stuffed animals bought especially for him, his little companions. And I just found out, doing this story, that they built this room especially for Wolfgang. They had it built this summer. They had workers come in and build the structure.
Wolf 吃饭的这个房间装饰着所有 Wolf 喜欢的东西，主要是毛毛虫和外星人。还有几个专门为他买的毛绒玩具，那是他的小同伴。我做这个故事时刚发现，他们专门为 Wolfgang 建造了这个房间。他们今年夏天建的。他们找工人过来建造了这个结构。
I mean, we know what school budgets are like. Can you imagine? They would never say anything, but can you imagine the battles that went on, with people saying-- you know, there had to be somebody on the staff saying, why should this one kid get $7,000 of our budget when think about if that money were to go to something on the playground so that all the kids could learn unicycling? There could be 100 unicyclers out there or there could be one kid whose meal time is a little bit more pleasurable and private. And I used to be a libertarian and a bit of an elitist, which I never recognized until I had a child with special needs. And I don't know how I would have voted. I might have voted for the majority. I might have voted for the unicyclers, thinking where's the bigger benefit with this $7,000?
我的意思是，我们知道学校预算是什么样的。你能想象吗？他们绝不会说什么，但你能想象工作人员之间发生的争论吗，肯定有人会说——你知道，肯定有人说，为什么这一个孩子要花掉我们预算的 7000 美元，如果那笔钱用在操场上，让所有孩子都能学习骑独轮车该多好？那可能会有 100 个独轮车骑手，或者可能是一个餐点时间更愉快和私密的孩子。我以前是自由意志主义者，甚至有点精英主义，在我有一个有特殊需求的孩子之前我从未意识到这一点。我不知道我会怎么投票。我可能会投给大多数人。我可能会投给独轮车骑手，想着这 7000 美元哪里会有更大的利益？
Now, I think that this boy, who is not doing so well on several fronts, deserves to not just survive his school day, but to actually thrive and have a wonderful day, even if that means a lot of effort. And what's amazing is that everybody seems to feel this way about Wolf once they meet him. Every single person that's around Wolf tries to come up with some different creative solution to a dilemma that's not their own.
现在，我认为这个在多个方面做得不那么好的男孩，不仅应该度过他的学校生活，而且实际上应该茁壮成长，有一个美好的一天，即使这意味着付出很大的努力。令人惊奇的是，每个人在见到 Wolf 后似乎都这样看待他。每个在 Wolf 周围的人都试图想出一些不同的、创造性的解决方案来解决一个并非他们自己的困境。
And it's not just school. His friend Sarah, who lives next door, is constantly exerting all this extra effort to be his friend, and she's only 11.
这不仅仅是在学校。他住在隔壁的朋友 Sarah 经常竭尽全力去当他的朋友，而她才 11 岁。
When the ice cream truck comes, what do you do?
冰淇淋车来的时候，你会做什么？
We usually just go and give him some ice or something. Then we put a little bit of food coloring in it so he can eat ice and I can eat the ice cream so we can actually have something, too.
我们通常就去给他一点冰块之类的。然后我们在里面加一点食用色素，这样他可以吃冰，我吃冰淇淋，这样我们其实也能一起吃点东西。
How do you feel when Wolf is watching you eat your ice cream?
当 Wolf 看着你吃冰淇淋时你感觉如何？
I think it's kind of not OK because he doesn't get to have ice cream. So it's not that easy for him, yeah.
我觉得这有点不太好，因为他吃不到冰淇淋。所以对他来说没那么容易，是的。
I was watching TV the other day, and I saw this Fox News guy talking about the school budget in Massachusetts and how this judge just gave all this extra money-- three times as much money-- to the schools, and that a huge chunk of it was going to special needs. And his gripe with it was basically that we've already been pouring all this money into special needs, and where has it gotten us? Has it made them normal? No.
前几天我在看电视，我看到那个福克斯新闻的家伙在谈论马萨诸塞州的学校预算，以及那个法官是如何给予学校所有这些额外资金——三倍多的资金——而其中很大一部分要去给特殊需求教育。他对此的抱怨基本上是，我们已经投入了所有这些钱用于特殊需求，结果得到了什么？这使他们正常了吗？没有。
There are stragglers, and there are shooting stars, and that's just the way it is. That's being realistic. But how can you go on thinking that way when you put it in terms of an actual boy's life? How can you say to him, because you can't eat normally, you would cost too much and it's inconvenient to the staff and the other children, so you can't come in.
有人落后，也有流星，事实就是这样。那是现实。但当你把它变成一个男孩的生活时，你怎么能继续那样想？你怎么能对他说，因为你不能正常进食，你会耗费太多钱而且对工作人员和其他孩子不方便，所以你不能进来。
Last year, I was trying to get Wolf into overnight summer camp for the first time, and he was denied due to his G tube. Can you imagine if a kid was not allowed to go to camp because he has a wheelchair? But I think not eating is just so unusual that people don't know what to think. So they're forced to be creative, and that's not always easy, especially in a group setting when you have all these other people to think about, too: campers, staffers, the campers' parents. So I ended up threatening to sue the camp for discrimination, and suddenly, they got over their discomfort.
去年，我第一次尝试送 Wolf 去过夜夏令营，但他因为胃管被拒绝了。你能想象如果一个孩子因为有轮椅而不被允许去营地吗？但我认为不进食太不寻常了，以至于人们不知道该想什么。所以他们被迫发挥创造力，而这并不总是容易的，特别是在一个团体环境里，当你还要考虑所有其他人时：露营者、工作人员、露营者的家长。所以我最终威胁要起诉营地歧视，突然间，他们克服了不适感。
And once they met Wolf, they saw that he's a little boy, and he's not this scary proposition and a drag on their time. So they were all very kind and wonderful to him, and Wolf had a wonderful time. He had to gather around the campfire and see other kids eating marshmallows, but that matters so little against the fact that he now has memories of gathering around the campfire.
一旦他们见到了 Wolf，他们看到他只是个小男孩，他不是一个可怕的提议，也不是拖累他们的时间。所以他们对他都很友善和美好，Wolf 度过了一段美好的时光。他不得不围在营火旁看其他孩子吃棉花糖，但与他现在拥有围在营火旁的回忆这一事实相比，这算不了什么。
Sometimes Wolf says-- while he's watching other people eat-- I'm happy for you that you get to taste that. It must be so good, which, of course, I translate to I am so filled with sadness and longing, but thanks for inviting me anyway. It's worth it.
有时 Wolf 说——当他看着其他人进食时——我为你得到那样品尝的机会感到高兴。那一定很好吃，这当然，我翻译为：我充满了悲伤和渴望，但还是谢谢邀请我。这是值得的。
Lisa Carver lives in New Hampshire.
Lisa Carver 住在新罕布什尔州。
Well, our program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website with production help from Todd Bachmann, Will [? Reichel ?] and Kelsey Dilts. This is Kelsey's last day with the program, which means that it is a terrible day for all of us. We wish her the very best.
好了，我们的节目今天由 Diane Cook 和我本人制作，Alex Blumberg、Wendy Dorr、Jane Feltes、Sarah Koenig 和 Lisa Pollak 参与。我们的高级制片人是 Julie Snyder。Elizabeth Meister 负责我们的网站，Todd Bachmann、Will [? Reichel ?] 和 Kelsey Dilts 提供制作协助。今天是 Kelsey 在该项目的最后一天，这意味着这对我们所有人来说都是糟糕的一天。我们祝愿她一切顺利。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for free or buy CDs of them. You know, you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, best-selling books, even The New York Times, all at audible.com.
我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目或购买 CD。你知道，你可以在 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至是《纽约时报》，都在 audible.com。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who installed a new suggestion box here at WBEZ with a stack of paper forms, and some pencils, and these instructions:
WBEZ 管理监督由 Torey Malatia 负责，他在 WBEZ 安装了一个新的建议箱，里面放了一叠纸质表格、一些铅笔，以及这些说明：
If you can't get what you want by verbalizing a problem, stick a pencil in your arm. Somebody's going to listen. Throw a fit. Scream, cuss, carry on like a little kid. Threaten to kill somebody. Somebody will listen to you.
如果通过语言无法解决问题，就把铅笔插进手臂里。总会有人听的。发脾气。尖叫、咒骂、像个小孩一样胡闹。威胁要杀人。总会有人听你的。
Management tips from the greats. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
来自伟人的管理秘诀。我是 Ira Glass。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。